قصه امومه واصرار وعزيمه بطلتها صحفيه
وشاعره ومقدمه برامج وناشطه في العمل
التطوعي انها طبيبا نضال حسن الحاج حيث
يحتفل متابعوها بالسودان هذه الايام
بتخرجها من كليه الطب بتقدير امتياز
متفوقه على زملائها تعتبر نضال من
الشخصيات التي يجتمعوا على حبها ابناء
السودان ولديها قاعده جماهيريه كبيره حيث
يفوق عدد متابعيها بموقع التواصل فيسبوك
مليونين متابع ويساندها محبوبها كمتطوعه
فهي صاحبه منظمه القدره التي تهتم باطفال
الشلل الدماغها
احيه فيكي اولا الطموح فيك الاصرار وحي
فيكي هذه الامومه نضال يعني كاتبه وصحفيه
وشاعره مقدمه برامج واليوم عدت الى مقاعد
دراسه وتخرجت بامتياز كطبيبه ودي اعرف
اللحظه اللي فكرتي فيها ترجعين لمقاعد
الدراسه الحمد لله رب العالمين هو التوفيق
من ربنا الاول
ومتى ما وجد الهدف همم
والعزيمه والاراده والدعم الناس اللي
حوالينا متى ما بقى النجاح باذن الله يعني
متاح الحمد لله رب العالمين هي رغبه في
الاول بعدها كان يمكن الوضع الصحي لطفلي
همم الداني دافع كبير في انه انا همم ارجع
الى الدراسه بعدين انقطاع 10 سنوات ويمكن
يعني تخرجت قبل لها من ثلاثه كليات لكن
اظل الطب طموح وهمم وجود كريم زاد الطموح
همم الطموح والحمد لله
واحنا بنح معاكي كمان احبابكم 10 ونحبك
شديد معنا هون في البرنامج اليوم همم نضال
يعني عندما يتعلق العمر في الابناء يعني
عيوننا لهم فنحن نفهم موقف هيك ونفهم دافع
اتجاه ابنك لكنك في كلمه التخرج يعني
شكرتي الدكاتره وقلت بانهم كانوا ضوء في
ظلمات جهلي فلماذا لم تكتفي بالاطباء لكي
يرعوا ويهتموا بابنك بالذهبتي ابعد من ذلك
وتخصصتي في الطب وهو يمكن السؤال يكون
منطقي اذا انا كان هدفيه لدراسه تطلب هو
تقصير الاطباء انما كان هدافي لدراسه الطب
بوجود كريم همم هو همم حوجه تقوم لانها
تعرف حال الطفل لها ان تكون مرافق لمريض
غير ان تكون طبيب عارف يعني شنو المريض
محتاجينه فيمكن دي واحده من اهم الاسباب
اللي خلتني ادرس الطب ااه الحاجه الثانيه
انه تمنيت انه اخدم ااه من المنطلق بتاع
الطب وتحديدا ااه يعني زراعه الخلايا
الجذعيه باذن الله اخدم فئه محتاجه لخدمه
همم زي ما كان كريم في وقت ما محتاج
للحاجه نضال بحكم انك الدكتوره شاعره
فماذا تقولين ابيات شعر في وصف حب شخص
يعنيك حب ابنك حب الاهل هي كثير من
القصائد يمكن جاءت واحده منها قبل شويه
ابوي فانا باهدي ابيات لامي باقول عنك يوم
كتبته كلام الصبح حرف الكلام مسروق وين يا
يما فيك نضمن القوافي يا حقوق وكل الدنيا
رجالت الخيول رحلت وبعدت اي احساس غير
هواك في السوق وقالت زي كلامي عليك قالت
زي حديث عليك امي مو حالف وامي محاله لكن
مثل الحلال
[موسيقى]